you guys have some photos on facebook
that you've never backed up maybe some
precious family moments or some super
embarrassing college photos that you
should probably actually just delete i
have partnered with milio to show you
guys how easy it is to quickly export
save and import all of those photos into
milio i've actually been using my leo
for the past year to organize and sync
all of my photos across ios android mac
and pc check out my link to get more
information about milio and to download
for free time for the import connect to
facebook
it's happening what i like about miley
is it's not cloud-based and everything
is stored locally and synced on your
devices even if there's a server outage
somewhere your photos will be safe and
viewable at any time i have multiple
computers phones tablets my leo will
turn all of those devices into an
intelligent system for managing and
viewing all of your memories sure
there's probably something you might
want to forget but that's what that
little trash icon is for check out my
link to get started with my leo for free
and if you do choose to upgrade for 20
off their premium services your future
self will definitely thank you